Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
guardians of the galaxy 3 video marvel just made
some big announcements with the release of the
thor 11 thunder trailer obviously that gives you
a pretty good idea for where they pick up in the
storyline i'll talk more about what's going on
with adam warlock and there's also a one-off
prequel episode for guardians 3 that they're
releasing at the end of the year i'll explain how
that sets up guardians 3. they also just brought
back one of the big celestials featured in the
first guardians of the galaxy movie for another
story that i'll explain so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we've got more moon knight episodes and
doctor strange 2 is about to come out and it's
going to get really crazy i'll be doing videos
for everything it's going to be really cool
not me what just listening but just starting with
all the guardians of the galaxy stuff in the thor
love and thunder trailer this is basically the
timeline for where everything is taking place
and picking up obviously there's a big montage
of the guardians of the galaxy and thor with them
the asgardians of the galaxy whatever you want to
call it them slowly getting tired of all of thor's
comedy and just telling him to go off and do his
own thing but he gets a couple big costume changes
and obviously there's the montage of him getting
all swole the present day of thor love and thunder
is supposed to take place around the time doctor
strange two is happening so scarlet witch and
doctor strange are supposed to be messing with
the multiverse around the same time gore the
godbutcher is just going on a tear killing all
these gods and fighting thor one of the reasons
why doctor strange isn't on hand to try and stop
gore the god butcher from killing all the mcu gods
so the montage of thor with the guardians of
the galaxy and the ravagers is meant to take
place in the past so that part will probably take
place before the events of spider-man no way home
although i think based on the way they cut the
montage it's actually meant to be happening in a
relatively short time span like i think the funny
joke here they're playing with it is that he goes
from being fat thor to working out really quickly
into being swol thor like wow that didn't take any
time at all just to show you how lazy he's been
in the past like oh he could have gotten swole
anytime he wanted in no time flat just another
joke about his powers in being a god and one of
the reasons why gore the god butcher's killing all
the gods because a lot of them are really really
lazy but like when he shows up in his ravager's
costume and it's designed to look kind of like the
eric masterson thunderstrike costume from the 80s
and it's got some classic thor easter eggs like
the yellow boots he's got the world tree shirt
on he's even got that hat with the classic jack
kirby avengers logo on it and strongest written
in sharpie but like the thunder strike jacket
is a ravager's jacket that's why it's red that's
why during the montage you see him sort of walk
off and leave by himself wearing his old avengers
end game costume while the guardians are in the
middle of some random attack and you see star-lord
just roll his eyes into the back of his head like
he absolutely cannot stand thor like this becomes
the last straw the cree and the frost giants are
the only two real big blue skinned races that
we've seen in the mcu so far so i'm guessing
that this might be some offshoot of the cree
race but then they have that funny scene where
he tries to give him that sage advice about thor
finding his path in the universe and thor gets
all confused and thinking that it's star lord's
eyes that he's staring into thor then goes off and
finds out about gor the god butcher gets his next
golden thor costume upgrade with the pelt on it
then goes back to new asgard and you pick up with
the main part of the story in the guardians of
the galaxy take off on their own to go find the
2014 version of gamora and just continue with
the day-to-day of helping out and robbing people
earning money while they're trying to do that so
just based on the guardians of the galaxy trailer
footage and all this it seems like they take off
before gore the god butcher shows up and starts
slaying everybody peter quill would technically be
able to escape gore on a technicality because ego
the living planet told him that he was a little g
god and star lord is still half celestial but
technically the celestials are not actual gods
they're just really really powerful cosmic beings
a lot of you also asking if ego lied about being a
celestial no i don't think he lied about that i
think he's just meant to be a botched celestial
like a rogue celestial the way that irish and the
judge talked about it not everything always went
perfect but if peter quill were to boast about
being half little g god in front of gore gore
would probably still try to kill him just out
of spite but we've learned that adam warlock
is going to be played by will poulter james gunn
speaks very highly of him so i assume he's going
to be pretty badass during the movie he's kind of
like their version of a vision type character like
this perfect creation designed to destroy what
they hate the sovereign will give him a similar
mission to destroy the guardians of the galaxy
but just like vision wound up siding with the
avengers adam warlock will probably eventually
wind up siding with the guardians of the galaxy
and they'll find a way to stop the sovereign adam
warlock was evil when he was first debuted in the
comics but then he had a storyline like visions
in the mcu this big morality tale about him being
super enlightened super cosmic and super powerful
so trying to figure out what he was supposed to be
doing with all this power in the mcu but being a
generally good character that's one of the jokes
about vision like we talk about white vision
technically he and scarlet witch are like two
of the most powerful characters we have in the
mcu so they always had to find funny ways to
sidelight them in stories because like in civil
war vision shows up and almost stops everyone
dead in their tracks like if he'd wanted to he
could have taken out every single member that
was part of that fight but i think going forward
he will be kind of like a vision type character
like he'll work with the other mcu characters
in a more cosmic sense the more cosmic stories
and his storyline being evil turning good is
also meant to dovetail with what's happening
with nebula the younger version of gamora and i
believe even rocket story as a lot of you probably
seen they've flipped the nebula gamora story from
the earlier guardians of the galaxy films again
where it was gamora who had turned good and was
trying to rescue nebula and teach her not to be
so obsessed with thanos not be so evil they kind
of already started doing that during avengers end
game like nebula had become part of the avengers
and working with them and then she was trying to
save the younger version of gamora like listen
you don't have to be like this we become friends
we become sisters so that's going to be a big
part of the movie is the nebula gamora storyline
and i believe i mentioned this before but one
of the major villains or major antagonists
according to james gunn is going to be mirn
from the peacemaker series supposedly he's
going to be playing the mcu high evolutionary
james gunn said that he liked his performance
during the peacemaker series so much that he
brought him back for guardians of the galaxy
threes this big villain character wallah gave
me soldiers is that it's an apple dumpling gang
who are the apple dumplings incompetent
dinguses but they always triumph in the end
the rumor is that it's going to be mcu high
evolutionary who actually created rocket or
tried to upgrade him in the first place made all
those experiments to him because that is kind of
the high evolutionary's mo trying to enhance
everyone there was a big easter egg for high
evolutionary during guardians of the galaxy 2 the
planet that they crash land on is named burhart
that was an anagram for herbert edgar wyndham
the high evolutionary's original human name
just meant to foreshadow him eventually showing
up in the story he is super weird i cannot wait
to see what james gunn does with the character if
you're a big comic book fan too he's also got a
lot of deep cut connections to scarlet witch and
quicksilver's origin story but they might change
that for the mcu version of the character because
we have the multiverse they can always say that
the high evolutionary encountered young scarlet
witch young quicksilver in some alternate universe
in the trailer footage groot is still teenage
group but during guardians 3 he's supposed to grow
into his most powerful form vin diesel just called
himself alpha groot like alpha male thor will
also the director talk to me about how thor will
incorporate some of the guardians of the galaxy
which would be very interesting nobody knows but
maybe i shouldn't have said anything um but i
only have two words uh about that character and it
is alpha group basically what that means is he'd
be even more hardcore than the original version
you saw in the first guardians of the galaxy movie
and if we're casting lots early prediction is
that rocket is going to be the one to sacrifice
himself to save everyone this time and it becomes
a big callback twist to groot sacrificing himself
in the first movie that's kind of the art that
rocket has been on in the mcu like rocket starts
as a super guarded selfish character becoming
truly selfless by the end james gunn's been
pretty clear that he doesn't have plans to do a
fourth guardians of the galaxy movie but he did
say that the team would eventually come back in
the mcu and if they did come back it would be a
different roster adam warlock for instance was
a big member of the team during the story that
they adapted for the first movie karen gillan
also said that she really wanted to do a nebula
marvel series on disney plus so some of the team
will be back and you'll see some noobs on the team
the guardians of the galaxy 3 holiday special
this christmas is the prequel episode for the
movie it'll be live action required viewing and
james gunn said that it's inspired by the star
wars holiday special so it'll be a mixture of just
like the next part of the story and just a lot
of funny moments like a big part of the star wars
holiday special was introducing chewbacca's family
introducing the concept of life day which was
like the star wars equivalent of your birthday
and it was the first time they introduced the
boba fett character so it might be the first
time we actually see adam warlock on screen in
some kind of small cameo or maybe even the high
evolutionary the other huge announcement is that
they're also bringing back the celestial issan the
searcher for the new guardians of the galaxy time
travel story that's part of their new attraction
showing you more of what he actually looks
like in his full form they've tuned him up
a little bit from what he looked like in his
previous depiction in that first guardians of
the galaxy movie when the collector was explaining
the origin of the infinity stones the new project
is called cosmic rewind and because it's
a story outside the movies and the shows
technically i think it's meant to be alternate
universe but this is what he would look like if
they brought him back again in present day mcu
the collector never said that isan had died so
theoretically he's still alive out there somewhere
in present day and a member of the current version
of the celestial host but i will do more videos
on all the cosmic entities in the mcu the gods
the celestials as we get more easter eggs moonite
and doctor strange too are just the next place
that that's happening right now so if you have
any more questions about what's going on with
the guardians of the galaxy just post them in
the comments below everyone click here for my
brand new doctor strange 2 trailer video and click
here for my moon knight episode 5 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!